I'm Baxter Eve's and you're in the room
for the explainable a I talk so a little
bit about me to give you some
perspective on where my perspective
comes from my background is actually in
psychology in cognitive science more
specifically so I did a lot of using
statistical models for models of human
learning I did a lot of research into
social learning and computational trust
I moved on after grad school to more
moai specific roles in probabilistic
programming machine teaching and for a
while I worked in industry as a data
scientist doing mostly agriculture and
now I'm doing research in something
we're calling humanistic AI which is
psychologically validated AI that's
shown to mimic predict and improve human
performance and if anybody plays tf2 I'm
a medic main because somebody has to not
be a spire a sniper thank you and this
is a high-level talk about safe AI and
safe AI is something that's really
important to me I'm guilty of this and I
think other people are too but I get so
caught up in the adventure of solving
really cool complex problems that I lose
sight of whether the way I'm solving
them is appropriate for the domain that
I'm solving the problem for and so we're
going to be talking about explainable AI
has one potential path to getting
towards safe AI so I want to talk about
some of the problems with mainstream AI
and how we got them and when I say
mainstream AI I'm talking about the post
2011 AI that's appearing in the popular
press that's doing the big tasks at the
big company so mainly deep learning and
its derivatives and the other similar
type black box models so to begin a I
has really become ubiquitous and our
personal lives thanks to the rise of
internet business and social media and
the availability of cheap computing
through the cloud ai is no longer just
running behind the scenes on mainframes
at banks anymore it's everywhere all the
time
it's doing stuff like sending us
targeted ads it's recommending us
products to buy an entertainment to
consume it's doing image classification
to find adult content or copyright
violations or put dog ears on us on
Instagram in the past few years we've
even beat the best human players at NGO
and Starcraft
and dota and if we look at these tasks
that AI has really been kicking butt in
it has some common features or
constraints one there are big data tasks
so data are nearly free and unlimited if
you're doing ad targeting by tweets you
have more data than you could ever
possibly handle action takes priority
over learning you'd rather send somebody
and irrelevant add the no ad you'd
rather recommend an uninteresting video
than no video and the reason is that
there's little to no cost of failure in
fact doing the wrong thing is often
better than doing nothing at all so if
we're sending ads and we give somebody a
relevant and irrelevant ad we miss out
on a couple of cents for a click if we
give somebody an uninteresting video
they can click they're not interested
and tell us why so we can actually
improve the algorithm in that case we
actually win by doing the wrong thing
and since these are the constraints the
AI really grew up to tackle
we now have AI that is inefficient that
requires kind of expects a lot of data
to work that is opaque that hides its
knowledge away is difficult to
understand is difficult to use and
maintain and is brittle that can fail
unexpectedly in catastrophic ly and that
is easy to attack and this isn't a
problem until we start using it for
things that matter on a societal scale
so the things that keep us fed and safe
and well so things like biotech public
health or agriculture defense and
intelligence and these sectors we have
the opposite constraints of the
mainstream AI tasks now data are scarce
and expensive it's incredibly expensive
to run a clinical trial your data points
are costing thousands or tens of
thousands of dollars and take months or
longer to generate
action is dependent on learning so if
we're building a science-based product
we need to create a knowledge base to
build that product on if we want to
improve that product we have to improve
that knowledge and there's an iterative
scientific process that goes along with
that or maybe we need to recognize all
the risks associated with taking a
certain action so we can mitigate those
risks because now failure potentially
cost lives obviously if we're doing
something like designing treatment plans
for cancer patients we want to make sure
that what we're doing is definitely
hopefully going to make things better
but definitely not make things worse and
what we're seeing though is that AI
meant for these benign tasks is starting
to be adopted for high-risk tasks and
there have been some bumps so uber and
Nvidia they're self-driving car killed a
pedestrian they had to stop their trial
for a while to diagnose the problem and
it's really difficult because these
systems are difficult to diagnose
because they're opaque so they came back
after a while and they said to well two
things happened one the system chose not
to swerve because they because it marked
the lady on the bike as a false positive
that's from my understanding from the
reading and the other thing was that the
safety driver trusted the system
implicitly
and they weren't paying attention they
were on their phone IBM kind of ready
wait writing the way the success of
their jeopardy playing robot I guess
they decided that jeopardy wasn't the
most scalable business model they
decided to branch out and to other
sectors which I think was a smart move
and health care obviously a big sector
and to us as laypeople it might seem
like kind of low-hanging fruit
medical diagnosis and treatment seems
like flowcharts you look stuffed in a
book and it's really formulaic so they
train these algorithms up and they
started to sell them and have trials and
what they found was that in some cases
the agreement between doctors and the
algorithm was as low as 33% and even
worse in some cases it would recommend
things that were potentially fatal
like giving drugs that could cause
hemorrhaging to patients who already had
problems with bleeding and I don't think
that anybody actually did get hurt as a
result of this but if you read this
report that stat news did there's some
very colorful language by a bunch of
very angry and maybe exasperated doctors
that were a part of these trials so how
do we make safe AI safe when safety
matters because it doesn't matter all
the time it doesn't matter when we're
doing ads or video recommendations but
sometimes when it matters it really
really matters one potential way is
explainable a I so there's this program
through dark book called Xai and kind of
the motivation behind this is that DARPA
has probably spent more money on AI
research than anybody else and what
they're they found in the past couple of
years is that the AI they've spent so
much money on is not something they can
use in a lot of cases and defense and
the military when you make a decision
that's an order you put your name to a
piece of paper and you are legally
responsible for the outcomes of that
decision imagine if that was the case
for self-driving cars if the lead
engineer could go to jail
if the self-driving car caused any
damage also in the military of course
the lives of very of a lot of people and
the fates of nations are kind of on the
line and you don't want to potentially
start a war at the whim of what is to
you effectively a magic 8-ball so there
are some questions that we want to be
able to ask these systems to make
ourselves feel better to as DARPA put it
appropriately trust the system and
that's a concept we're gonna come back
to a whole bunch so we want to know why
did you do that why didn't you do
something else when do you succeed when
do you fail when can I trust you how do
I correct an error and so the way that
they envisioned this now is today we
have these learning processes that
create these functions that just somehow
relate inputs to outputs they're
impenetrable they're hard to understand
when you look at them and then they give
you an answer this is a cat P equals
0.93 and you're at your laptop with
lightning bolts coming out of your head
because you're super frazzled what we
want
is we want all new learning processes
that create interpret explainable models
that the user will interact with through
an explainable interface we want to say
this is a cat because it has fur and
whiskers and claws of course that would
also explain a dog so you get the extra
information about the parts of the image
maybe that help to explain that
so explainable AI has been around long
before the buzzword this is a nomogram
or Noma graph it is a figure that
perfectly explains a simple model and
this was invented in the late 1800s so
we have our model there at the bottom we
have our inputs SN R so these are the
things that we observe the data that we
get and we ever output T which is the
thing that we want to predict we find
our value of s for our input on the s
scale there we find our value of R on
the r scale for whatever input we cross
those two points with a line and where
they intersect on the t scale that's our
output so we've been able to perfectly
explain the knowledge of this simple
equation for all sets of possible inputs
but of course something like this
doesn't scale to the thousands or tens
of thousands or even more inputs that we
get when we're doing something like
image processing or something like that
or genomics expert systems these were
really popular in starting in the 80s
their software hardware systems where
you basically encode expert knowledge
onto a system to solve domain-specific
problems and you get a stuff a lot of
stuff that looks like flowcharts with a
lot of if-else statements you can give
it some data and it can use certain
heuristics to solve problems the problem
with these was that they're really
expensive it's super expensive to
develop these because you have to sit
down with people and encode all of their
knowledge and that takes a lot of human
capital to do the hardware was really
expensive to buy and to maintain and
after a certain level of expense because
this is a problem that there are humans
ready to solve you might as well just
hire someone at a certain point
and of course today there are things
that we want to do where there are no
human experts or it's very difficult to
encode that knowledge or procedural eyes
it so we want to learn to create experts
from data so explainable AI I guess
basically post 2011 post 2012 most of
the AI focus has been on deep learning
and within deep learning the flagship
task is image classification so most of
the work has focused on image
classification so we're seeing a lot of
stuff like this this is a highly cited
paper that proposes ways to kind of help
people to understand convolutional
neural networks it shows you how to go
layer by layer and kind of pull out the
feature Maps and see what parts of the
feature maps are really important but I
think the most relevant part of this is
this bit here so the image in the middle
is a heat map where each pixel
represents the probability of
classifying this image over here
correctly given that this gray square is
on that pixel so let's take this blue
pixel here in the middle we put the gray
square there and we see the probability
of correctly classifying that as a
pomeranian is basically zero because
we've removed presumably all the
important information there we can see
what the alternative classifications are
over here so if we put the gray square
over here and leave the bald area
visible it's going to classify it as a
tennis ball maybe if we move it to a
different area we classify it as a
different kind of dog and so on this is
a saline sea map so this kind of does
back propagation to compute a gradient
with respect to classifying correctly
and it gives us the important parts of
the image to classifying correctly in
kind of this way and you can see that
it's pulled the dog parts out of the dog
image and let the sand part behind and
sometimes there's lots going on in an
image and we want to pull out the
different pieces so there are
potentially lots of ways
to classify this you wouldn't expect a
machine to classify this as a dog man
playing an acoustic guitar but you might
expect part of it to be electric guitar
so the frets there and then the body of
the guitar explains acoustic guitar and
then the Labrador head explains Labrador
and part of this shirt here with I think
it's foot helps to explain that and
there are other approaches using heat
maps like this with different
interpretations that are computed with
different levels of complexity and speed
we can do similar things with text to
sew recurrent neural networks are big
and an LP literature so if we know the
type of thing that we want to predict
say we want to predict when we're gonna
see a quote or when we're gonna see a
comment and code or we want to predict
the depth of an expression we can do
that I think at this paper they use
cross-entropy to do that and this is a
slide directly stolen from the xai
program updates of course it's approved
see on the bottom I can steal it it's
okay but a lot of the teams there I
think four slides four or five slides in
this deck that were dedicated to what
the individual teams were doing and a
lot of them were doing helping to
explain deep networks so they grouped
them all together and kind of pulled out
some of the more salient examples so a
lot of what people are doing as and this
project is creating text explanations so
we see over here this has a text caption
for an image so it's a man in a jacket
standing in a slot machine and it shows
you which parts of the image were
important for generating that part of
the caption this one down here it
combines two types of neural networks
convolutional neural networks and
recurrent neural networks to learn how
to actually make these sorts of captions
and xai work is mostly focusing on
explanation because explanation is right
and the name there but there are some
problems with explanation one
explanation is being mostly built for
computer scientists by computers
scientists and this has been like into
letting inmates from the asylum so it's
we're asking the people who kind of got
us into this situation to get us out and
this paper by Tim Miller and peers how &
lisana Berg who are kind of a mixture of
both computer scientists and
psychologists to paraphrase it's bad
software comes from not thinking of the
user explainable AI researchers are
ignoring lots of social science research
on explanation and instead they're
relying around their intuitions and
their needs to design these systems and
they ought to stop doing that so Tim
Miller kind of wrote a follow up that is
a really long nice review of the
explanation literature for xai
researchers and he's saying that there
are two components here there's the AI
side and then there's the human
decision-maker that's interacting with
the AI so this research really needs to
combine three things it needs to combine
artificial intelligence social science
and human-computer interaction
literature's because people respond and
learn differently than machines
especially when interacting with humans
are things they anthropomorphize and
that's not a quote that's just my
addition there and to kind of make that
clear so back in that 90s a Watson or it
wasn't watched it was deep blue then it
was a different IBM computer playing a
different game deep blue B Garry
Kasparov and chess and this is when we
decided that we finally conquered chess
and deep blue made a really perplexing
move and Kasparov described it he said
it was a wonderful and extremely human
move I had played a lot of computers but
I had never experienced anything like
this I could feel I could smell a new
kind of intelligence across the table
and it turns out it was a mistake it was
a glitch it just
did this random thing and he attributed
this higher plane of reasoning this
intention to this machine and it cost
him the game and after reading this I
started playing my wife like this and
she won't play with me anymore
Watson almost snuck a wrong response by
jeopardy by Trebek so it's important to
note that Watson was not aware of what
the other contestants said so there was
an example of him
repeating Ken Jennings answer and they
having them having like a special orange
light to express embarrassment doing
that but in this case the question was
something to do with this odd feature of
Olympian Olympic gymnast Oh and so from
the 1920s Olympics and the answer was
what is missing a leg the guy was
missing a leg and Ken Jennings said what
is missing a hand and Trebek said that's
wrong and Watson said what is a leg and
Trebek said you know that's right but
it's actually not right because he said
a leg not missing a leg of course having
a leg is not an odd feature so Trebek
attributed this extra humanity to this
machine because tons of language is
context maybe most of language so if
you're sitting in an office with your
buddy watching all the the monitors
making sure the systems don't go down
and you say hey are you gonna be around
in the next five minutes he just says
yeah go take a break
he didn't ask to take a break but he
knows from the context so this is one of
those weird things that people do to
make them more efficient problem to
explanation doesn't actually solve the
problem
so because explanations don't prevent
problems they tell you they offer
excuses as to why they happened so
saying that you labeled someone as a
false positive really doesn't help
anybody it might help things in the
future but we like to get to things
before they happen it also doesn't help
to answer a lot of these questions that
are called out in this program so that
will help you answer why you did that
not something else but it doesn't really
help you get to when do you succeed when
do you fail and can I trust you how do I
correct an error a problem three
explanation is not really knowledge so
an explanation tells you a little bit
about why an action or prediction
happened but there is so much knowledge
inside of that machine that created that
prediction or action so they're using
neural nets for particle accelerator
experiments and we would like to know
what is inside the machine without
having to ask it why it thought a
certain collision was classified a
certain way we'd like to use
interpretable models to do that an
interpretable model is trivially
explainable like a linear regression
here we can say if we had to guess
someone's height by their way we would
assume someone is taller if they weigh
more the problem of course is making
models that are interpretable in general
is really hard making them powerful and
performant even more so so there's a lot
of work going on here and it's kind of a
slog but people are working at it
explanation makes inappropriate trust
worse we saw a couple of examples how we
tend to anthropomorphize things and that
can cause problems that can cause us to
over trust but people are biased to
trust because more trust means faster
learning if I trust no one
if I go around in the world thinking
everyone is a liar and no one will tell
me the correct answer to anything I
can't learn from anyone I can't read a
book I can't ask my family I can't rely
on my teachers I have to go out like the
first human being and build a
civilization from scratch trial and
error everything and that's no way to
learn if I trust everyone implicitly
then I can accept everything everyone
says without question and so I can
accept a lot of information quickly I
can learn a lot quickly I can stand on
the shoulders of giants and I don't have
to reinvent the wheel of course we want
somewhere in the middle but there is a
reason to bias towards trust the problem
is that these deep networks are brittle
and unpredictable and we really ought
not be trusting them in a lot of cases
so
if you just google attack deep learning
you're gonna get hundreds of results and
this is an example of real-world attacks
on image classifiers like you might see
in a self-driving car so what is this
nope it's a speed limit 45 sign what is
this also a speed limit 45 sign so
having a heat map overlaid on these
smudges telling you that this was
important to labeling as a speed limit
45 sign doesn't really help you all that
much and this is not something that
we're easily fooled by as human beings
if that wasn't brittle enough for you we
can change single pixels and images and
change the outcome of a classifier and
this is kind of an attack using that
salience the map that I showed you a
while back we can compute a Jacobian on
that salience EMAP and attack that
network and so we can make a make the
system think that a deer is an airplane
reverse cats and dogs think horses are
dogs and birds are frogs and all sorts
of weird stuff by just changing one
pixel which might look like a
compression artifact if you are help
putting a heat map in my an explanation
that might also look like a compression
artifact so this is a very scary attack
so how do we fix these problems I don't
know how to fix all of the problems but
I think we can fix a lot of them if we
just go ahead and embed machine
knowledge into the human mind we just
take that knowledge we do Johnny
mnemonic or matrix or some other Keanu
Reaves thing and we get that knowledge
inside of that person and if we could do
that a lot of these questions change
they're no we're no longer relying on
the machine to answer them we're
introspecting we ask why did I do that
why didn't I do something else so when
do I succeed when do I fail when can I
trust myself and if we get into a
situation where we feel icky we can step
back and think about it like we do and
that's all good and well to say but how
do we actually go about embedding
machine knowledge into a human mind well
how do we embed human knowledge into a
human mind we teach
so we can put that some well let's let's
explain it first we'll do a audience
participation thing so we're gonna play
a game called the rectangle game and
somewhere on this board is a hidden
rectangle and it's my job to teach you
where that rectangle is so let's say
it's here and I'm going to teach you by
giving you examples if I put example
down and it's inside the rectangle the
computer is going to label it as a
circle if I give you an example that's
outside the rectangle the computer is
going to label it as an X that's a
negative example so let's say I give you
these two examples and the computer
labels them where's the rectangle let's
beat
because if it was a bigger rectangle I
would have put the points further out
because I'm trying to teach you where
the rectangle is and it can't be smaller
because that's inconsistent with the
data so if you were a computer you'd
actually need four more examples to
constrain that but I was able to teach
you one of infinitely many rectangles by
giving you two data points because you
know how teachers act you know what my
intention is you have all that social
context there so we can put this to math
we have two equations you don't need to
know what they mean I will explain it so
the top one says the teachers choose
examples that tend to increase the
learners belief in the correct
hypothesis so I'm taking a specific
learner with specific beliefs into
consideration and I am trying to choose
data to move them to a specific
hypothesis learners on the other side
they understand this they're aware of
how teachers act so they update
accordingly while also taking into
account their prior or current beliefs
so can we do this for things that are
more interesting than rectangles sure we
can approximate this recursive set of
equations to do teaching image
categories and so our colleague April
Swinehart
put a head camera on walked around in a
park and around campus and called these
images she did some processing on them
that's why they look I guess low quality
but it's a techniques from the
perception literature to kind of make
them perceptually similar in certain
dimensions and so we separated these
images into indoor images and outdoor
images and we did some feature
extraction using some techniques from
the perception literature to pull out
perceptually salient features of these
images and we learned a two category
model for each of these image types so
we have on the top a two category model
for the indoor images so the cat in one
category is close to the origin here and
the other one is farther away and that
we have the two category for the outdoor
environment you can see that the
categories here a lot farther apart
then we're going to teach these
categories by either central images or
mean images these are images that come
from the center of those categories you
would consider them maybe the maximum
likelihood images or the most
prototypical images of those categories
or we use that teaching model to select
the set of images which has the highest
likelihood of producing the true relief
in the end the learner then we're going
to evaluate our performance of teaching
by having participants label ambiguous
data and the ambiguous data are the
images that sit between the two
categories so they're the ones that kind
of overlap here in the middle and that
are going to be the most difficult to
distinguish and these are the results so
what we found was that for the outdoor
images there wasn't really much of a
difference between the two teaching
methods the clusters here you can see
are very far apart and when you look at
the images you can see they're sort of
split into plains and wooded images but
for the indoor images where the clusters
are much closer together
folks who got the mean are the
prototypical images they performed at
chance but people who got the teaching
data they performed better than chance
and they perform statistically better
than the people who got the mean data so
we did have some success in transferring
some machine knowledge which was fairly
arbitrary to a human being but you can't
just transfer any old knowledge it has
to be compatible with a human being so
we repeated the same experiment that's
what this gmn thing is we used Gaussian
mixture models as our knowledge
representation here we also tried
representing the knowledge of it
differently using techniques from image
processing rather or image processing
and classification rather than
perception so we kind of broke the image
apart we created this visual vocabulary
which we put into a bag of words model
and tried to teach that using the same
methods and it just didn't work it looks
like it worked so teaches
little bit higher but that's not
statistically significant so this sort
of teaching helps people to recover
machine knowledge but only if that
knowledge is compatible with the human
that you're teaching two problems with
this is that it's recursive math and
teaching is harder than learning so when
you're teaching you have to consider
what the learning learner is going to
learn from your teaching and also
learning from teachers is harder than
teaching and teaching to learners
learning from teachers is harder than
learning from teachers and we really
don't like recursion when we're doing
machine learning especially when we're
do we're having to compute integrals of
integrals of integrals of integrals so
there's a lot of work here to make this
scalable and that's exciting work if not
slow but we're getting there so to wrap
up AI has some problems that make it
unsafe sometimes sometimes it doesn't
really matter for a lot of things it
doesn't really matter but when it
matters it really matters and
explainable AI can help us get there it
can help us make to AI it can help us
make AI safer the spirit of explainable
AI encompasses more than explanation
it's about making these machines
completely transparent and intuitive not
just to the researchers but to the
end-user the stakeholder the person
who's going to jail if the decision
doesn't pan out really to do that we
need to think of the human user because
humans learn a lot differently than
machines especially when you can get
them to anthropomorphize the system that
they're interacting with to do that we
need to focus more on interpretable
models that are trivially explainable
that are compatible with the human users
rather than adding extra models on to
our uninterpretable models we saw that
teaching is effective for certain types
of models but we need those models to be
compatible with human beings and a lot
of this is why DARPA is looking for new
machine learning processes to to
interface with human beings and there's
still a long way to go but what's good
is that we're having these conversations
people are thinking about it DARPA alone
has dedicated basically two billion
dollars to programs that are fixing the
existing problems with AI making them
more human making them interact better
with humans and for us that gives us a
lot of really cool problems to solve
there's paradigm shifts coming and I'm
really excited to be a part of that and
so thank you and I'm happy to take
questions I saw a hand in the very very
back there yes
I'm not quite sure that I follow
[Music]
yeah that's I mean that's gonna require
some thought I haven't thought about
that way yeah there she was wondering
about the trade-off between explanation
and anthropomorphism I'm still sorry
missus not sure I understand come to me
after and we'll great yeah there yeah
[Music]
so the question is how do we deal with
explainable AI if it's performing worse
than on explainable AI so there have
been ways of adding uncertainty to I
guess deep learning and stuff like that
quantifying uncertainty is one way but
if your uncertainty doesn't mean
anything that's kind of a hard thing I I
really don't know how to answer that
question other than some cases it might
pay to just admit that you don't know
and not do anything then pretend that
you don't so if you are 99% accurate in
a non explainable model but the other
you know one person of the time you do
something really tragic that's bad so I
think I mean it's definitely a
case-by-case basis and you just need to
decide what the risks are of failure so
be careful with the models that you use
in the green shirt there yep yep yep
I think it's gonna be domain-specific to
a degree I think putting things out that
are kind of removed from human language
might help things like that so giving I
guess images rather than words so if you
give a figure of a probability
distribution or something like that that
might help but what we're going to need
to do is we're going to need to pair
very closely with psychologists and
social science researchers and actually
run the experiments because I can't
answer that question without running an
experiment and that's really important
to do
uncertainty is quantities yep I think
what we we can't make it I don't think
we can necessarily make it less fragile
I mean it
making domain-specific models is one way
and I think probabilistic programming is
a really good approach to that because
you get uncertainty as a part of that
you can design a model based on your
understanding of a specific domain so
you're not just saying here's the input
here's the outputs make something you
can kind of model the mechanics of that
domain and if it's probabilistic you get
uncertainty at every step and you can
propagate your error through and things
like that so I think it's more about
becoming aware of the uncertainty
embracing it and knowing what to do with
uncertainty that's going to help there
yep so he was asking about other methods
to achieve safe AI apart from explained
ability and I think a really simple one
is responsibility so who is on the line
when the decision fails and I think
that's a big ethical question that we
have yet to work out we've yet to work
it out with self-driving cars the
decision was that we're the safety
driver is the one responsible maybe it
should be us maybe we should be
responsible maybe if what we built goes
into production and kills somebody maybe
we should go to jail because we're the
people that have the best understanding
of those failure modes so I think there
are some ethical considerations and I
think if we're all scared to death of
screwing up then I think AI is gonna
look a lot different got might be harsh
but that's that's one way no AI for
anyone
perseverance inside here
the assistant interesting
I think I'm certain that there is but I
don't know it off the top of my head I
know there is a upcoming DARPA program
called Ceylon and it's about kind of
baking in human capabilities like
transfer learning and things like that
so if you're interacting with worlds
where the rules are changing or you want
to analogize to different worlds or
things like that things that people can
really easily do like I can learn go on
a 9x9 and I can also kind of play on a
on a standard-sized board but machines
have to be retrained so I think
introspection is going to come into play
there when you have to really realize
the limits of what you know and what you
can do with it but I'm sorry off the top
of my head I don't know I can't give you
citations right there
[Music]
so could change the interpretation that
that kind of sensitivity is just scared
the problem is you can get uncertainty
from a convolutional neural network but
it doesn't really make sense so you can
yarn Gaul has a really cool blog post
it's got a lot of like animations and
graphics and he was talking about
explaining uncertainty and I'm overtime
by the way but it was talking about
classifying like making a fruit
classifier and then giving it a frog
what does it say it's you want to have
high uncertainty in that situation and
someone did that and with his code and
he said it said with high certainty it
was a frog or it was a green apple or
something like that the frog was with
high certainty a green apples so it
doesn't really make any sense we need to
have and systems that their uncertainty
kind of maps to what's actually going on
in the world go thank you
[Applause]